My name is Drex and I am here to pump
you up. Yeah, nobody in my audience is
actually old enough to get that
reference, are they? But real talk,
spinning po can put a lot of strain on
our shoulders, especially when you get
into the realm of flowers and extensions
and the like. So, I had a Patreon
supporter reach out to me and ask if I
have any exercises that will help build
up that shoulder strength and endurance.
And in point of fact, I do. So, I'm
going to share with you my shoulder
workout to improve your poi in this
video.
Drex here from Drexfactor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I'm going to
give you a full workout that is going to
build that shoulder strength and
endurance. But before we dive in, I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
friends of the channel. Big thanks to
Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow
Toys, Pyroera Light Toys, and Ultraoy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. You can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video. It may be challenging
towards the beginning of your flow
journey to be able to do all of those
big moves that take up a lot of room,
but the good news is is that you can
build up that shoulder strength. And I
have chosen six of the most punishing
exercises that I can think of in order
to help you get there. And we're going
to start things off as you always should
with
step one, warm up.
So, because we don't actually use our
full range of motion with our shoulders
through most of our day, it's usually a
good idea to warm up our shoulders just
a little bit before diving into a
workout like this. Here's what it looks
like. You can do this either with or
without music, but basically, you're
going to do each action going both
directions eight times. We're going to
start by rolling our wrists out going 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 eight times. Roll them
inward. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 eight times. Roll
your shoulders back. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 eight
times. Now roll them forward once,
twice, three times. 4 5 6 7 8. Now
you're going to fold up your arms and
roll your elbows back once, twice, three
times. Four, five, 6 7 8. Now roll them
forward. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 eight times. And
then you're going to reach each hand up
towards the ceiling. But be careful not
to shrug when you do so. Don't bring
your shoulder up next to your ear. Think
that you're only going to reach up as
far as you can without picking your
shoulder up. I reach right, left, right,
left, right, left, right, left. Again,
right, left, right, left, right, left,
right, left. Cool. So, this will get
your arms nice and limbered up as well
as lubricated to be able to move around
in any direction that you want. I
actually still do this warm-up every
single time I pick up my poi. So, if
it's good enough for me, it's definitely
good enough for you. Step two,
conditioning.
So, this is a conditioning exercise I
picked up years ago that I still give to
my students to this day and that I still
sometimes practice myself. Basically, it
involves taking three different
exercises and doing eight reps of eight
with each one of them. Let me show you
what that looks like. So, the first part
of this consists of us starting with our
arms going straight out to either side.
And with our arms straight, we raise our
hands up until there's a 90° angle
between them. We go back and forth
between horizontal and angle, horizontal
and angle. The next set involves us
taking our hands from being straight out
to the side to bending our elbows to
bring our hands next to our ears. We go
back and forth like this. The final
grouping involves us keeping our hands
up near our ears like this and opening
and closing our hands like so. We want
to do eight groups of eight for each one
of these. It's going to look like this.
In the interest of time, I'm not going
to show myself doing the entire exercise
here, but it is available if you want to
see an extended version of this video
over on my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I'll include a link down in the
description. Goodness, I'm sure starting
to feel the burn already and I hope that
you are too. So, let's dive into some
exercises that use the PO. Now, exercise
three, extensions.
All right. So, the first trick I want us
to explore as we're doing this shoulder
workout is our extensions. And
specifically, we're going to do our
extensions going both directions and in
every timing and direction mode. We're
going to start out in together. Same
here. Going 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 one times. And
switching back. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 times.
Then going into together opposite. 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 eight times. Switching back. 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 times into split opposites.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 times. And then
switching back. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 eight
times. Now we go split time. same
direction going 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 eight
times. Switching it around. 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 eight times. And dear friends, that is
just the beginning. Exercise four,
flowers. All right, let's augment those
extensions with some inspin flower
petals. The reason being that having to
stop our hands is going to build up our
shoulder strength as we go through them.
So, we're going to do just like we did
with the extensions going through every
timing in direction mode in both
directions. Starting off by doing in
spin in together same once, twice, three
times, four times, five times, six
times, seven times, eight times. Going
back. 1 2 3 4
eight times. From there, we switch into
together opposites. 1
2 3
7 eight times. And switching back. 1 2
eight times into split time opposites. 1
2 3 4
6 7
eight times. Going back the other way. 1
3 4
6 7
eight times into split time. Same
direction.
Once
twice, three times. Four
6 7
8. Going back. 1
7 and eight times. Cool. Now we're
really starting to build those shoulders
up, aren't we? Exercise five, horizontal
stacks.
All right, so horizontal stacks are
interesting because they completely
consist of performing top stalls and
pendulums. But part of what makes this a
challenge is that you have to keep your
hands above your shoulders the entire
way through. This of course is the mel.
It is kind of the basic horizontal stack
that most of us learned as our first
one. Uh if you don't already know how to
do it, I will go ahead and include a
link to a tutorial on how to do it down
in the description here or up in the
cards. But suffice it to say, I want you
to go back and forth across your body at
least 10 times with this move. Going to
the right once
and twice
and three times
and four times.
Five times.
Six times.
and 10 times. The good thing about this
exercise is that it forces you to keep
your hands up the entire way through and
it normalizes that feeling of keeping
your hands at eye level or just above,
which is going to be super helpful. All
right, so before I introduce our final
exercise to you, I do have a quick favor
to ask. If you come this far, I'm
assuming that it means that you have an
interest in po and flow arts, which is
great because I make lots of videos on
those topics. If you'd like to sign up
to find out when my latest video drops,
you should subscribe to the channel and
ring the bell. That will make sure that
you are the first to know when I drop a
new video, and it makes everybody
happier in the process. Yay. All right,
friends. Are you ready for the most
punishing exercise that I know for your
shoulders?
Exercise six, plane breaks.
So, every single exercise that I've
given you so far with the PO technically
can be done without actually getting
your hands above eye level. We can do
our extensions closer to us. We can do
our in spin flowers in such a way that
our hands never get past eye level.
Heck, we can also do our horizontal
stacking in such a way that we keep our
poi close to our shoulder level. But
this next exercise, we absolutely have
to get our hands above shoulder level in
order to accomplish. And that is because
we're going to be playing around with
plane brakes. That is we're going to be
playing around in this place where we
switch our poi from vertical planes to
horizontal planes like so. And
specifically, we're going to do it in
anti- spin. I'm going to bring my arms
out in pendulums. And I'm going to make
sure that my hands are at eye level as
I'm doing this. And what I'm going to do
is when my pendulums go out to either
side, I'm going to basically a quarter
of a circle. I'm going to go from facing
down stage to facing over to my stage
right. And as I do that, I'm going to
spin my poi in over my shoulders to do a
little anti-pin pedal. Boom. Like so.
From here, I'm going to go back to my
pendulums. And then the next time
they're pointed out, I'm going to take
that quarter turn back to facing down
stage. From here, I'm then going to do
one, two pedals to going around to
facing up stage. And one, two pedals to
going back around to facing down stage.
Then I'm going to do one, two, three
pedals. So I come to face stage left.
One, two, three pedals to come back
around to face down stage. Now I'm going
to go all the way around. 1 2 3 four
pedals to face down stage. And 1 2 3
four pedals to face down stage once
again. Now I'm going to go 1 2 3 pedals
to stage left. 1 2 3 pedals back to down
stage. One, two pedals to upstage. One,
two pedals to down stage. One pedal
stage right, one pedal stage or down
stage, rather. So I would consider that
one rep. Do five total reps of that.
Building up 1 2 3 four pedals and then
going back and then working your way
back down to one pedal. You have to keep
your hands off the entire time. This is
going to do so much to help your plane
breaking and also it's going to be such
a workout for your shoulders and build
up so much endurance in them. Awesome. I
hope your shoulders are really feeling
that. I know that mine are at this point
and I hope that this helps you build up
your strength and endurance with your
shoulders to do all kinds of po tricks
down the road.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a huge
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now. Thank you.
You all rock. And if you would like to
get your name in the credits or access
to a whole host of awesome rewards,
including being able to suggest video
ideas to me such as this one, you can go
check out my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and sign up. Not only will you be
getting access to awesome perks, but
you'll also be helping me out in my
mission to bring PO spinning and flow
arts to the whole wide world. So, go
check it out, please. And thank you. And
if you're curious how good a workout
spinning poi is, I actually did a video
on that very topic where I wore a Fitbit
and tracked my progress over the course
of a 1h hour PO workout. Uh, and the
results were actually really surprising
to me. If you'd like to see what they
were, please go check out that video.
The link is down in the description as
well as up here on screen. In the
meantime, thank you so much for
watching. Be sure to get out and fill
yourself today. And I'll see you with a
new video real soon. Take care now.